please welcome the one the only pete
holm hi hello hello hello
my hair is shorter hello i got a haircut
hello you look good
oh thank you very much you guys look
great really hair and makeup really i
woke up like this
[Laughter]
pete i'm so excited about this new show
your character tom gets laid off and
becomes a professional bowler tell us
everything also do you hit turkeys
because i love
saying turkey went bowling and can you
explain what a turkey is and tell us
about the show
oh my god you want me to explain a
turkey is a is a fowl it's a bird it's a
delicious uh dry meat
that yeah you only get if you hit three
strikes in a row in bowling i believe
well done
thank you very much i'm impressed thank
you thank you very much were you a
bowler before this
only you know we did candlepin because
i'm from boston that's this is on the
show we do uh 10 pin bowling wait for
the candlestick pad handle pin please
it's like a hard cantaloupe that you
roll at smaller pins you can hold it in
your hand is it a real melon
i know i'm picturing full honeydew i
tried i thought i went you know what
what i'm gonna say yes it is a real
melon because i want you living the rest
of your life telling people that in
boston we bowl with fruits with fruit
yes these balls that we used on the show
and we use real balls they're like ten
pound balls the ones that you put your
fingers in yeah roll ten pound ball
right now
you would have been a real fit on the
set because we couldn't stop everybody
would say somebody get peter's ball bag
where's pete's ball back
oh my god this is my kind of show
welcome home and you are our kind of guy
pete in fact will you hit some headlines
with us
i will all right thank god because we
always need your take on things all
right
ross your story up first we've got a
biggie when it comes to relationships
here's a question how soon is too soon
to say i love you
i know well and good talk to
relationship experts who put an actual
number on it they say you should wait
until at least three months before you
say it oh the audience agrees they do
uh they say three to five months is the
ideal window for saying i love you and
it works the other way too if you're not
feeling it by five months then houston
we may have a problem
i think there is no too soon it's just
like don't say it first because
right
there's such a risk in that oh god i
don't that makes me so uncomfortable i
love you
anything
so you won't say it first rossi i didn't
say it first no well he said it first to
me have you ever said it first to anyone
no
ross let's do a trust exercise right now
say it to me i promise i got you i love
you pete
i love
it
you
it worked well i meant it it's like it's
like a trust fall it's like a trust fall
you just gotta do it once by the way
three months these are our these are the
same people saying to go to bed at 9 39
these are made-up things yes
thank you in fact is an uber rating
arbitrary pete do you have your uber
rating
i did i looked it up when you guys were
looking yours up
and i just got drew's by the way i do i
have you oh god oh no what's yours first
pete
uh 4.73
is that good this is very good
it's not a 4.89 but it's good
ross has a better rating but he's more
intimidating about saying i love you see
these are what all all of us humans
that's my problem i get in the uber and
i go i love you with my whole heart and
i'm probably freaking some of these
people out
listen i will say we have good uber
ratings and drew barrymore yours is
really good too it's not as good as ours
4.68
i'm so mad you are the nicest person
i've ever met but yeah i bet you it's
the late the running wait it's that i
keep them waiting
all right you know what
here's the goal i'm gonna get that uber
rating up that is a challenge
you can do
and we're gonna ask jimmy fallon his
uber rating all right next story we're
uh talking potty pastimes oh
we've checked about checking your phone
on the toilet apparently most people do
use their phone on the toilet this is a
thing fine um but it turns out uh there
might be a snacking on the toilet thing
happening
i know metro reports a new poll found 18
of adults said that they've had a nibble
while they dribble no stop it um yes
actually one
or number two was not specified
so let's just say one in six people
admit to snacking on the ball
um
okay
ross no don't even ask me i do not i do
where do the crumbs go
you just open your legs just a little
bit it goes straight down
you do the same thing on the couch just
brush it off straight down tell me you
don't eat on the toilet
i'm on the toilet right now
[Laughter]
well pete holmes we love you so much
will you please come back as soon as
possible so we can talk more
about how we roll which premieres
tonight everybody at 9 30.
eastern
on cbs okay love you so much i love you
guys i love you ross don't forget
[Music]